[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout le
sommaire de ce mardi 23 avril des
animaux fantastiques tour à tour mignon
ou effrayant à guyancourt l'artiste the
du présente son bestiaire des sculptures
en terre cuite qui veulent attirer vos
regards
ok sous bois direction le brésil et ses
terres indigènes de 50 artistes exposent
ensemble à l'espace philippe noiret pour
sensibiliser aux peuples autochtones et
versailles se prépare à vivre dix jours
très jazz du 9 au 19 mai le versailles
jazz festival revient dans la cité
royale
une programmation in et off à découvrir
elle crée un bestiaire fantastique
l'artiste et du passionné de conte de
fées sculpte la terre cuite depuis une
dizaine d'années pour donner vie à
toutes sortes d'animaux ses oeuvres sont
exposées à l'hôtel de ville de
guyancourt jusqu'au 25 mai aurélie rose
et calypso vanier the duke se crée un
monde l'artiste guyancourt toiser
passionnés de fantastique
influencé par tolkien et marion zimmer
bradley est sculpte des personnages
mignons ou effrayants j'utilise de la
terre noire généralement que je patine
après avec des produits qui s'apparente
aux produits qu'on utilise pour
travailler sur le bois et j'y inclus
souvent des éléments extérieurs que je
chine dans les brocantes des éléments
plutôt de vieux métiers utilisé par le
cordonnier les formats chaussures
les lunettes les machines à écrire des
choses comme ça the duke travaillent la
terre depuis près de 30 ans mais elle se
met à la sculpture depuis une dizaine
d'années pour cette exposition elle
rassemble des animaux qu elle dote d'une
intention humaine dans le regard ou dans
la position prendre le regard des gens
que ses sculptures attire le regard
le regard des gens et d une interaction
en fait c'est ça de cette façon là c'est
provoquer une émotion chez le spectateur
et moi cette émotion elle passe par le
regard par le côté parfois un peu
effrayant parfois drôles des pièces que
je présente pour légendaire une
quinzaine de pièces et rassembler et
certaines pourraient vous surprendre
une exposition anniversaire maintenant
il ya 300 ans moore et madame de
maintenon à cette occasion le château de
versailles consacre une exposition à
l'épousé secrète du roi louis xiv
une soixantaine d'oeuvres et document
retrace sa vie au sein même de
l'appartement qu'elle occupait au
château regarder son histoire pourrait
faire penser un conte de fées madame de
maintenon est née françoise d'aubigné
dans une prison à niort avant de
connaître les coulisses du pouvoir va
connaître une ascension exceptionnelle
puisqu'elle va traverser les années 560
en devenant la gouvernante des enfants
du roi et de madame de montespan et
finalement le roi qu'il a dédaigné un
petit peu va finalement se rapprocher
d'elle et elle va épouser celui qu'on
appelait à l'époque le plus grand roi du
monde en 783 elle devient une presse que
rennes et va vivre à versailles
l'exposition penser de manière
chronologique emmène dans les allées du
pouvoir dans l'appartement qu'elle
occupe à l'époque elle ya vécu 35 ans
est un lieu assez emblématique puisque
louis xiv lui a octroyé cet appartement
au moment où lui donne une charge auprès
de la dauphine c'est à dire la brute de
louis xiv il trouve cette astuce pour
lui donner un appartement
on a beau être la maîtresse du roi on ne
peut pas être logés gratuitement à
versailles une reine dont on sait
finalement peu de choses avec une
soixantaine d'oeuvres et de documents
les équipes du château replace madame 2
non dans l'histoire deux expositions
simultanées autour des terres indigènes
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois accueille près de 50
artistes qui vous invite à réfléchir
notamment à ses coûts aux conditions de
vie de ces indigènes à l'origine de
l'idée claudia campos artiste
plasticienne franco brésilienne bonjour
bonjour et vous êtes accompagné de
juillet à keiko vous aussi vous êtes
artiste plasticienne déjà claudia
comment vous est venue l'idée de cette
exposition
en fait c'est un projet qui est à la
cinquième édition
lille a commencé en 2005 lors de l'année
culturelle du brésil en france j'ai
répertorié à l'époque des 225 peuples
différents au brésil un indigène et que
je voulais évoquer cette question et
l'engagement des gens et j'ai distribué
des flacons avec des terres et puis
chaque flacon risque correspond d un
peuple il des puis je commençais
vraiment à me questionner d'approfondir
le sujet j'organisais des expositions
collectif est donc là pour ces moments
là 5ème édition
elle a proposé mme bartz est un projet
ouvert à tous le monde dont
la personne
elle s'engage à créer une oeuvre
artistique n'importe quel support dans
les arts visuels pour évoquer un peuple
que j'ai dû suggère si la personne n'a
aucun lien avant donc c'est un peu le
but de ces projets alors vous exposez
vous même dans cet espace
un moyen aussi pour vous ne serez
peut-être la fragilité de la nature de
certains de ces peuples autochtones
oui la fragilité même de notre
patrimoine humain
la fragilité des enfants qui sont quel
est l'avenir qui on propose aux enfants
indigènes au nom des jeunes
donc je me sert de support de la nature
l'eau terme est propre l'art quand je
suis très touchée par des articles dans
la presse qui parle de ses sujets donc
j'essaye de transmettre cette émotion
avec très peu de moyens pour que les
publics soient touchés par ces cette
cause là vous utiliser toutes les
techniques possibles en tant qu artiste
plasticienne vous ne vous n'avez aucune
barrière on voit quelques unes de vos
oeuvres
voilà à l'écran exactement donc il ya
beaucoup de désinfection travailler avec
l'eau bloquer en est en train de
de perdre avec l'aquarelle avec la terre
il ya beaucoup de terre aussi que
j'évoque la question des terres que
c'est très important pour les peuples
indigènes du brésil ou ailleurs et en
même temps je lance un manifeste avec
une étoile qu'il ya beaucoup d enfants
avec des vêtements qui sont tendus
devant ces images de ses enfants pour
parler de vivre ensemble malgré la
distance physique nous sépare cette
distance elles pourraient être des idées
préjugés
l'éloignement par rapport les
territoires des continents culture
n'importe
mais comment hambourg et tous les
humains vivre ensemble malgré nos
différences donc c'est ça que j'évoque
je pense les plus importants dans les
deux projets
cette exposition je le disais alors elle
est douce parce que vous inviter
d'autres artistes à vous joindre à se
joindre à vous il n'y en a une en
plateau mais il ya aussi des artistes
originaires
originaire de ces peuples là tout à fait
donc c'est la nouveauté de cette édition
là parce que la dernière était il ya dix
ans c'était au mémorial des peuples
indigènes à brasilia et depuis malgré ma
laurence parce que j'apprends beaucoup
avec cette question c'est parce que
maintenant il y a l'artiste contemporain
d'origine indigène de plusieurs peuples
qui souhaitent parler eux mêmes par
eux-mêmes c'est ça le but de ce projet
là aussi donc il y a
quand même cet artiste d'origine
indigène donc des cinq peuples
différents et de danser à découvrir
mais oui pour qu'ils puissent eux mêmes
à parler de ce qu'ils souhaitent c'est
le but de ces dialogues avec le pain de
jeunes non indigènes pour qu'on puisse
comprendre qu'il y a des peuples que
sont encore en vie parce que parfois on
s'est pas rendu compte qu'il y a plus de
300 plants à existants mais voilà ces
peuples il y en a un je vais peut-être
très mal prononcé nombreux prenez moi le
peuple
shereni tcc voulgézac eco vous le fait
découvrir dans vos oeuvres déjà
qu'est ce qui vous a plu dans le projet
de claudia campos moi j'ai rencontré
claudia quand il ya eu l'année
france-brésil et pierre bon j'étais
assez touchés par les airs ou de claudia
et puis après bon et des recettes
ce projet est un père indigènes qui se
consacre depuis cinquante pas beaucoup
de temps et un bond par rapport aux
indigènes
comment que j'ai commencé à montrer
c'est en fait c'est leur respect pour la
matière c'est ça qui vous a plu qu'il
veuille attirer chez eux
et puis bon disons que au niveau
écologique et tout ça donc actuellement
c'est un problème mondial
mais bien avant enfin bon ou à laser je
suis allé à leur rencontre
1 quand je fais un tour du brésil là
j'ai des amis un brésilien qui a des
parents attentifs
en effet le seul apte à déchets sur
indices et j'ai pu rencontrer à ces
peuples et moi je suis du département du
sud précise donc les gars c'est pas une
raison des migrations
nous disons que les peuples autochtones
on voit pas on a oublié on ne voit pas
mais département s'appelle pana c'est un
mot indigènes
justement vous et vous les avez
rencontrées vous êtes vous-même né au
brésil deux parents japonais vous avez
fait vos études en france ce
multiculturalisme qui vous intéressent
aussi que vous souhaitiez mettre en
avant pourquoi c'est de mettre en avant
en commun toutes les ressemblances et
tout peut-être les différences aussi du
fait d'être de plusieurs cultures
1 parce qu'ils m'ont canton dié célian
brésilienne s'est pas tout compact c'est
pas c'est un mosaïque de cultures et
pire je pense qu'il faut valoriser
les indigènes sont big cultuelle donc
moi je ne sais plus combien de culture g
mais au moins à la racine g2 parce que
j'étais en japonais gd encore des
générations de la culture japonaise et
aussi parce qu'il est dix ans j'ai
l'impression donc ça doit remonter très
très très loin
les indigènes les peuples précommande
bien ça original tâche j'ai l'impression
tous ces liens à tous ces ponts on est
un peu pris par le temps donc je vais
devoir couper
merci tout les deux d'avoir accepté
notre invitation la rencontre avec ces
peuples indigènes a commencé le 19 avril
dernier
mais l'exposition est à voir jusqu'au 12
mai prochain à l'espace film aurait des
clayes-sous-bois alors n'hésitez pas on
parle maintenant pour ou dans peut-être
qu'on vous dit souvent vous avez une
jolie voix ou que vous amuser à faire
rire votre entourage sans jamais oser
monter sur scène le 7 8 comedy club vous
donne sept minutes une fois par mois
pour vous tester et nous avons assisté à
l'un de ces rendez vous regardez
le jour elle son professeur au lycée et
en élémentaire
amis depuis plus de dix ans mylène et
audrey sont passionnés de chant elles
font leur troisième scène aux 7,8 comedy
club
c'est plutôt des chansons à texte on ait
duo guitare voix et avec des chansons
plutôt à écouter et à chanter quand
electronics et quant à l'école et on est
tombé sur facebook sur une annonce du
comedy club et on se dit bon bah voilà
c'était le format qui nous convenait
quelques minutes se lancer on se lançait
elle les intéressés ont sept minutes
pour convaincre depuis le mois de
février
une fois par mois le tire-bouchon un
restaurant de houdan se transforme en
scène à l'origine des membres de la
compagnie soudanaise l'aviateur sourds
s'est ouvert aux musiciens ou chanteurs
aux humoristes magicien slameurs et donc
on réuni entre 8 et 10 artistes par
soirée voilà et le sait faire c'est
faire kiffer le public voilà on
accueille les novices ceux qui ne sont
jamais montés sur scène et qui veulent
s'essayer une première fois on accueille
effectivement des amateurs qui font de
temps en temps et puis on peut
accueillir des professionnels des gens
qui se disent tiens j'ai j'ai un texte a
attesté un sketch a testé une salle de
40 places rapidement complète dans le
public des haines et des artistes et des
curieux qui reviennent régulièrement ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est énorme
et ensuite c'est la possibilité donnée à
beaucoup de jeunes voire de moins jeunes
de s'exprimer et d et d'évoquer tout
leur talent quoi on a passé une super
soirée des artistes au top sur une
diversité c'est vraiment hyper sympa
c'était tellement dans la première fois
que du coup j'en viens à chaque fois
deux autres rendez-vous sont encore
prévues les 16 mai et 20 juin prochains
serez vous dans le public ou sur la
scène
il revient pour une seizième édition le
versa et jazz festival c'est du 9 au 19
mai et pour faire le point sur ces
rendez vous nous avons joint en plateau
lucia mamos moreau vous êtes membre de
l'organisation bonjour bonjour est ce
qu'on peut dire que cette année encore
ça va être éclectique
oui tout à fait comme les autres années
avec les spécificités de que ça se passe
dans plusieurs lieux pas qu'à versailles
a book aussi jeu ou josas et à tous où
les nobles aulas versailles grand parc
et rsa et gros pack est très représentée
mais même à versailles vous n'êtes pas
au même endroit tout le temps il ya
plusieurs lieux joue à la royale factory
la salt à son bureau le thème nos
pensées tout à faire c'est l'idée
d'investir la ville verse un grand parc
oui oui exactement alors il y a dans un
festival toujours un hymne et un oeuf en
général chez vous dans le film il ya pas
moins de seize dates de programmer oui
en fait ce sont quinze concerts et un
master class
sara lazarus ils ont plié bien au
conservatoire faire sa master class pour
donner quelques vis de son talent
peut-être tout à fait quelques conseils
comme chanteuse au chanteur est
aujourd'hui ce qu'elle fait ce à la
veille de son concert qui lui a lieu le
mardi 14 mai alors la toute première à
toute première date c'était le premier
jour d'ailleurs à savoir le 9 mai avec
le laurent derache trio un petit mot
rapide de présentation oui c'est les
spécificités de laurent derache
c'est que au lieu d'utiliser un piano il
utilise son accordéon et voilà donc il
faut il faut le voir parce que c'est la
cause des routes on n'en trouve pas
souvent de l'accordéon dans des trios de
jazz normalement c'est lé piano on
utilise le piano basse batterie et donc
là c'est un accordéoniste qui joue
avec une basse électrique verra t on
m'écoute un extrait
[Musique]
alors là on a entendu un trio
professionnelle mais vous donner aussi
la chance à des jeunes hilliard ensemble
samedi 18 mai tout à fait alors si
jeunes d'où vient-il alors et il a eu un
concert où il a eu aussi donc là un
concours pour des jeunes justement pour
donner opportunité à ces jeunes de
participer et de se faire remarquer dans
nos festivals et là il a eu aussi à
polytechnique jazz battles et dans cette
jazz batterie tôt il a trois groupes qui
se présentent aux roches dans les bars
et restaurants de versailles et les
jeunes générations tout a failli sont
tout à fait d'eux des jeunes donc ces
mots d'alain de tarab et les doigts de
la main
bon d'accord alors une scène jeune mais
sur les quinze dates il ya beaucoup de
professionnels certaines sont reconnus
dans leur métier et avant d'en parler je
vous propose qu'on écoute un autre
artiste au plus tôt cette fois c'est une
femme
manu le prince elle se produire avec
alain jean-marie à la salle de la vous
écouter
[Musique]
à
1 7 me saoule
apa
ce pas
[Musique]
oh
ve
[Musique]
je suis
oui
l'isie
manu le prince c'est un coup de coeur
pour la programmation
oui pour moi oui c'est moi qui l'a
invité à venir avec alain jean-marie
qu'est ce qui plaît chez elle c'est
parce que bon elle fait du jazz de la
bossa et je trouve ça que c'est
magnifique de chanter la bossa elle vous
entraîne à elle vous donne envie de
danser j'imagine oui de voyager le
voyage est alors comparé au brésil le
placer un peu la même chose alors on a
beaucoup parlé du in mais le festival
propose aux siens of vous en avez dit
quelques mots tout allant voir parling
et des lieux plutôt insolite
les restos rui alors des restaurants
donc il a le le ravin bleus c'est un
nouveau lieu à pas à versailles qui
vient de s'ouvrir il n'y a pas très
longtemps à peu près d'un an et demi
c'est tout à fait ça ressemble les caves
de jazz à paris et donc je vais jouer là
bas
le jce des jim et c'est là-bas et après
je vais je aussi le
le 16 justement la première partie de
concert de demain juste pour en revenir
au off
même si ce sont dans des lieux un peu
originaux plutôt insolite c'est toujours
de la musique on reste tout le temps
dans le festival tout donc j'ai festival
vous vous souhaitez que je dise dans
quel endroit peut-être ou peut-être
quelques artistes à ne pas manquer
quelques dates
il y a mv gaiement faut pas manquer et
là à l'ena morales il a aussi
les trois de la jazz bateau qui je vous
ai rien à la télé et donc il ya aussi
qu'est ce qu'il y a
il faut pas que j'ai oublié après pour
ne rien oublier nous il ya un petit
bandeau qui va s'afficher qui s'appelle
versailles jazz festival point fr c'est
le site du festival il n'ya rien n'a
manqué vous avez donné quelques dates le
chamanisme auront donc les gens se sont
fait une idée vous avez quelque chose à
rajouter
aurélie taquet oui il faut venir
nombreux à ce festival parce que c'est
un festival de grande qualité
il a pour tous les âges pour tous les
goûts c'est vrai que c'est très
diversifié et il a pour les enfants même
donc il a de quoi découvrir le jazz à
toute heure les enfants qui viennent
avec les parents justement introduire
les enfants à la musique
merci du chamanisme roland verser
quelques jours à patienter avant de
profiter des premières notes de jazz le
versailles jazz festival débute le 9 mai
prochain
dire qu il a un site donc pour les gens
qui nous en tant est qu'ils
s'intéressent et keith comprendre il
devient voilà oui pardon il y avait
aussi ce serait difficile il faut
regarder les sites et il faut regarder
la page facebook et la page facebook
c'est noté merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
de littérature
à présent nous en parlions la semaine
dernière avec une lime de nos invités la
librairie indépendante de montigny
autonome le pavé du canal met à
l'honneur des auteurs locaux avec des
rencontres
lisez locale les auteurs voisins peuvent
ainsi échanger avec leurs lecteurs
marylène iapichino des échanges et des
dédicaces dans les mêmes conditions que
les grands noms de la littérature
contemporaine
lisez locale en est à sa neuvième
édition et comme d'habitude ce sont des
auteurs yvelinois qui sont derrière la
table l'idée en fait sur chaque fois
c'est de faire venir des auteurs locaux
ou en tout cas de petites maisons
d'édition qui n'ont pas une grande
communication
comme les auteurs de littérature et
voilà de les promouvoir et de faire en
sorte qu'ils soient un petit peu connu
du grand public d'un roman d'actualité
sur une mer qui s'imaginent montrer sa
vie en immersion au président de la
république emmanuel macron à une analyse
des rapports entre l'infrastructure de
l'internet et la politique
cette session orienté sciences humaines
accueilli au total cinq auteurs de 15
heures à 19 heures visite toujours que
je ne vis pas de l'écriture mais que
l'écriture me fait vivre voilà au sens
large du terme
évidemment je fais pas partie de ces
auteurs qui ont la chance de ne pouvoir
faire que ça mais je ne fais quand même
que ce afin que ça j'ai un métier à côté
charles dans l'immobilier mais un mais
c'est ma vie c'est le centre voilà mes
battements de mon coeur sont là une
manière de varier d activité de la
librairie qui a eu 30 ans le 1er avril
et qui entend bien résisté face au géant
d'internet c'est sympa ça change
l'activité strictement commercial ça
permet d'avoir d'autre chose de
rencontrer les gens mes deux voisins je
ne connaissais pas leurs livres
ça m'a donné envie de les lire prochaine
rencontre lisez locale le samedi 15 juin
consacré cette fois ci à la littérature
[Musique]
elle signe à quatre mains raconte à deux
voix près l'une gay para et marie
boccaccio mais ils sourds et entendants
autour d'un même répertoire trois
séances de bon compte sont proposés 10
heures et 11 heures à partir de 2 ans et
15 ans et 15 heures à partir de 5 ans
regardez le chacal aïd
ça sent la chair fraîche ouvre un mois
la porte
fans de marvel et des avengers est sans
doute impatient de voir le dernier
épisode les ugc skywest et vélizy vous
propose de voir et revoir les deux
derniers épisodes de la saga dans un
marathon
toutes les informations sur sur le site
du gc et on regarde un extrait de la
bande annonce et parfois la meilleure
solution si de tout recommencer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous ces gens mourir
n'arrête pas de bien à tout le monde
qu'il faut avancer
[Musique]
le faut
mais pas nous
[Musique]
même si nous n'avons qu'une chance
infime
notre devoir
envers ceux qui ne sont plus parmi nous
c'est laisser plonger dans l'univers de
l'illustration jeunesse christine
destour donne les secrets de la
géométrie des verticales et des couleurs
primaires lors d'ateliers ça se passe ce
samedi 27 avril une activité en lien
avec le festival graine de papier c'est
la fin de ce site une culture merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]